[Musique]
Je suis le record le plus progressiste de
quiconque court pour l'univers si
quelqu'un qui courrait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
évier de cuisine
vous bénisse tous que Dieu protège nos troupes merci merci merci
[Musique]
notre président Obama dans  fait incarné je
pensais que tout ce qui était bien à propos de qui nous
étions Donald Trump est en fait sorti
et a empoisonné leur âme vous savez qu'il
enflamme il attise les flammes des groupes haineux
suprémacistes blancs pour annoncer que je me
présente à la présidence pour vaincre Donald
Trump et pour unir  et reconstruire l'Amérique
[Musique]
ceci
merci et bonne nuit Oh [
Musique]
ou un choix différent je pense et un
type de leadership différent Je n'ai pas
passé toute ma carrière en politique Je fais maintenant
juste des discours que je construis  équipes je
cultive de bonnes idées et je me tiens
responsable des résultats Je suis candidat à la
présidence
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] [
Musique]
bien au-delà de
[Musique]
le vice-président dit que ce n'est pas le
moment de prendre un risque avec quelqu'un de nouveau mais je
dirais que ce n'est pas le moment de prendre le
risque de se rabattre sur le familier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements] [
Musique] [
Applaudissements] [
Applaudissements]
[Musique]
idée et
à propos de la personne qui peut transformer ces
idées en action Je suis Bernie Sanders Je suis
candidat à la présidence
[Musique]
tu n'achèteras pas cette élection
[Musique] Oh,
il ne s'agit pas seulement de nourrir Trump, il
s'agit de transformer ce pays  il s'agit d'
avoir le courage de s'attaquer à Wall
Street les compagnies d'assurance les
compagnies pharmaceutiques l'industrie des combustibles fossiles le
complexe militaro-industriel
Je me tiens ici aujourd'hui pour déclarer que je suis
candidat à la présidence
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements  ]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Je veux un gouvernement qui ne travaille pas seulement
pour les riches pas seulement pour les grandes
entreprises pas seulement pour la NRA Je veux
un gouvernement qui travaille pour nous et
c'est pourquoi je suis ici  et c'est ce que je
vais garder
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]